as opposed to just fighting this is the
really interesting thing about brave is
as opposed to just fighting in and being
treated like an ad blocker
you're providing an alternate there's a
there's a philosophical idea here that
might change the nature of the internet
with the basic attention token
yes well maybe what is basic attention
token bat
and how does it work okay i'll tell the
story first by saying
how i came to it i realized for a long
time at firefox we were
dependent on this google search deal and
i thought you know
now that chrome's out maybe that's going
to go away and they just
at some point google will say you know
firefox
you know like old yeller you saved me
from the rabid beast now i have to shoot
you in the head
yeah done your job sad but true goodbye
and what could we do and i think this
mozilla doesn't know what to do this is
something that i couldn't solve there
and i don't think they can solve
but i thought why is the browser that's
the sort of passive servant of these big
tech companies why is it
a blind runtime for ad tech javascripts
including from google
why doesn't it block some and if it
blocks some why can't it reconnect
users readers fans with publishers
creators websites
why can't it help people make direct
payments or
even possibly get an ad revenue share
for private ads that are placed in the
browser
the ads are all placed in the browser
some people have this sort of model that
the server is painting the ad
into some you know flash uh
combined package or into some giant
image and then it all gets sent down
that's not how it works
all the ads you see on the web are
placed in your browser by
calling out to various ad tech partners
and
google's among them and and so if you
block those scripts you
you break the the advertising
flow of money from the brands and their
agencies to
the publishers and if you want to
reconnect it
directly with the user you have limited
choices the user generally isn't going
to sign up with a
ach bank connection or a credit card the
the publisher isn't going to
sign up the user accepted as a
subscriber and then they're going to
overcharge you
because they want you to cross-subsidize
all the content and buy more than you
read and all that stuff
and how many you know people are doing
great who are big names like new york
times in washington post
but how many subscriptions are you as a
user going to pay for this is why
startups like tony hale's scroll are
trying to do a portable
subscription system but by the way just
a small tangent there even the new york
times is really
annoying how difficult it is to
subscribe yeah there's way too many
clicks they don't make it easy i had
friends a few years ago i think they
fixed this who
would pay for the paper and then they'd
go online and they get
up charged for the digital and they
there was no break there was no
connection between them
yeah um but publishers are not that
technical and they're
they can't all get you to subscribe you
can't have a thousand subscriptions
so for a long time people talked about
micro payments there was blendal and
netherlands which came to the us but
didn't grow and i thought if you have
just a browser
and it's protecting you by blocking all
this ad tech tracking junk it can
provide you an option
that uses cryptocurrency to let you
support your your favorite
sites and even youtube channels and that
way prototype with bitcoin
and that meant the user had to be of
means to contribute and willing to
contribute
but it could be done on the bitcoin
blockchain and it could be fairly
efficient even though bitcoin went
through a period
when we had this prototype running in
2016 into 2017 where bitcoin was very
congested and
very slow to confirm and the fees got
very high um
and a lot of users who were not bitcoin
maximalist or even experienced
we we helped them out by embedding a
coinbase buy widget and they had the
income to buy but it was hard it was
like
do i buy five dollars a month but the
fee is like 450
i better buy in larger batches right
then they're like i don't want to
own that much bitcoin so it became this
this painful thing
and the real idea that i had of private
ads that pay the user
a rev share couldn't be realized
alone in that kind of system in
these cryptocurrency systems especially
with the blockchain we switch to
ethereum you can have smart contracts
the bitcoin system is not turned
complete so what you can do with the
script is more limited
but you can still do sort of clever
things
even with bitcoin script what we wanted
to do was sort of a
three-sided ecosystem we wanted users
creators or publishers and advertisers
and we wanted the advertisers to put
money in just like they do today
but without going through the googles
and the app nexuses and all these other
ad tech companies
because those companies take out a huge
cut the guardian in the uk once did an
experiment for a month they bought out
their own ad space
they put in a pound and they were paid
30 pence 70
was coming out to the intermediary
vendors they were using
wow and that's like the opposite of what
the app store does the app store takes
30
and gives the publisher 70 so pretty
broken in the old
days of the superstation tbs the media
owner would get 85 so these splits have
become
really unbalanced and the middle players
the the ad tech vendors are taking out
way too much money
and they're doing something worse which
has been noticed they're
they're letting um not just the malware
vendors
but also the ad fraud side which fakes
the publishers
and click bait merchants
come in and steal traffic from good
sites because
once you have a certain audience
identified at one site jason calcon has
told me this about his experience with
i guess it was in gadget uh which site
he was running but
once he started using an ad partner that
was sharing his audience information
across multiple sites
he saw his competitors stealing all his
traffic and then what's worse is the
clickbait sites that just have
much cheaper rates steal all that
traffic and that facilitates
you know fraud it facilitates um fake
news
all sorts of problems so brave blocks it
and then we give users the ability to
give back and because we invented the
basic attention token and ethereum we
can do this three-way split
and we can give users a share of the
revenue and if they want to take it out
they can
now unfortunately for us and for all
blockchain the regulators are saying
we're going to have to know who you are
there's there's the
the treasury department's uh fincen uh
agency there's the office of foreign
asset controls ofac
there's the um you know other regulators
in the federal government that
take a very dark look at things like
money laundering and
sending money to someone named osama bin
laden so
compliance starts to come in and even
now they're threatening for pure bitcoin
sending to some address
if you're a coinbase you're gonna have
to know who who's at that address you're
gonna take the actual identities of
people involved yeah
now with coinbase members you sign up
and they know you and they comply with
the regulations they're a regulated
money services business and um
but if somebody's using their own
self-custody
so-called self-custodial wallet where
they have the hardware private key
and they're not named and they want to
send to that address
our friends in the federal government
are talking about requiring at some
threshold knowing who that is
so some threshold that's unreasonable
it's not that big
um yeah i don't know how this will play
out i think crypto's here to stay i
think the beauty of being able to send
peer-to-peer without any bank in the
middle without any
you know huge wire charge and two day
delay and all that nonsense
it's beautiful and i've used it i love
it but we're pragmatists to brave about
crypto and we
realized that anything like a revenue
split we can't facilitate without being
licensed in a certain way and it
requires knowing who the user is
so our default mode doesn't know who the
user is it instead imputes to the user's
browser
some of the revenue and allows that
browser to steer it back
to the creators and we do have to
identify the creators
but as things improve and you know who
knows how it'll play out
there should be kind of a day when this
this full vision can be done more
uh fully on a blockchain but regulations
and the practicalities of
today's blockchains which are not that
fast and not anonymous over time you
fingerprint yourself over time
we do some of this with the browser so
one of the ideas of the basic attention
token
is to make a hybrid system that's
stronger than blockchain alone it's the
browser
and the blockchain and the browser is
this trusted endpoint software it's this
universal app
everyone uses browsers the bigger the
screen the more you're in the browser
unless you install
you know fat clients for things um i use
slack on
on mac os and it's it's like a browser
it's based on an electron framework we
used to use and it's just
it's not that great i i some people at
brave use slack in
brave as a in the browser browser yeah i
use that often yeah
and i noticed on the ipad i use apps
less um the smaller the screen
you know the browser got handicapped by
apple and android both and it
also uh you know can be slower or not
have the right you know affordances the
user interface or the the
security uh limited apis but in
principle with the right permissioning
you can make the web
browser just as good as any app you make
it be a super app
and that's part of our mission at brave
so we want to have the economics that
got captured by these big tech companies
through tracking
and through social networks we want to
block that for your own safety and then
let you opt into a cleaner world
where you keep your data defended in
your browser and you can actually
realize value from it
so the way our ad system works i
mentioned it being private but how does
that work
we don't see your data at all all
browsers are sort of the mother of all
data feeds your history
all your searches at all engines each
engine sees the queries you send to it
but it doesn't see the others but the
browser sees them all
machine learning in the browser that you
can opt into can study all that
in a very complete way and do a better
job than google does google has
you know cookie and scripts across the
web from acquiring doubleclick they have
youtube they have android they have
search which is still their big revenue
line
but they don't see everything the
browser sees everything and if it can do
a good job locally and this is not
advanced machine learning this is
not tensorflow this is like svms now
naive bayes
then you can match intense signals
intent signals
from those data feeds searches the
queries the history
how much you're scrolling down a page
how much you redid a search
it's all blind browser algorithm we
don't see that data
and then pick the best ad from a fixed
catalog
per day and the catalog is fixed across
a large population per day and it only
updates the date once a day because new
offers come in and old ones expire
sometimes every week or every month and
that
catalog and there can be many such
catalogs is
sold by our direct sales team and so
we're making
an anonymous audience available to
advertisers without the advertisers
tracking them
instead each browser is a little machine
learning system that's picking the best
catalog entry now the catalog is not the
ads those are big right it's a video or
a web page
it's just the link to an edge cache and
there are many such edge caches we're
not trying to
protect them from seeing your ip address
it's not really feasible
we could use tor but we don't yet um and
some key words about the ad
so it's basically like metadata and a
link and that's what the catalog
consists of and that's what the machine
learning picture and the machine
learning
is learning about the use specifically
locally
in order to choose from the catalog of
different ads couldn't this possibly be
like a multi-billion dollar is this
taking on
the google ad so like what
i mean one question to ask the there
seems to be some really profound ideas
here that
that are different than what the
internet has grown up to be
if brave or something like brave
the ideas the fundamental philosophical
ideas underlying brave win
out and runs 95 of the internet
how does that change uh the
what what are the major things these
changes about the internet so social
networks and then the creatives like
youtube creators and all that kind of
stuff
so let's talk about that first of all if
brave gets 95 i'm going to demand a
recount because i
i won't believe it uh i don't know i i
think uh
we're trying to put things into web
standards that can be standardized
across browsers so
the main value of brave will be the
trust users have in us and our ability
to
give the best deal to users so 70 of the
gross ad revenue we give to the user and
if they
go through that kyc process i mentioned
they can take it out they can also give
it back they can take some out give the
rest back they can add
basic attention tokens to give back some
of them turn off the ads because you
just don't like ads but they put in 20
a month but i believe zuko of zcashframe
does that and that's very generous
because
the browser is just anonymously based on
his browsing sort of keeping score on
how much time he spent on this
video on that website and if those sites
verify in sort of a like getting a
domain certificate fashion they can get
paid
they can get uh part of his 20 a month
so that vision could go big and if it
does i hope it's across multiple
browsers i don't
know that uh they'll all compete well on
the quality of the ads the quality of
the ad blocking and tracking protection
those those are subject to competition
it'll take a while to standardize them
but i think
that would be a better world it would
have less counterparty risk
fewer fee takers in the middle really
just the browser we're taking 30 percent
um sort of the app source app store
split and if we get bigger maybe we can
take even less
social networks creators if you look at
youtubers a lot of them
the indies that are getting some size
are getting sponsorship deals
uh they're using patreon they're
encouraging people to subscribe and give
them regular money through patreon
but that's centralized your patreon so
there's censorship hazards there's a
five percent fee
what if that were web standard what if
brave pioneered it first and we took
three percent and we did it in a way
that was
through your browser so we couldn't
censor it um that's brilliant
yeah do you think it could be
standardized across browsers can like
internet explorer come in again and and
uh yeah protocols are easy to copy and
that they're meant to be interoperable
so
it's there's a risk there and the loyal
users might be tricked into leaving you
or they might
because of that distribution power you
might end up getting stomped
um i don't know i can't predict the
future i think anti-trust is back on the
case finally in the us and and
certainly in europe gg comp is doing its
thing so i'm hopeful that we'll have a
period of innovation
you know people were talking elizabeth
warren was talking about breaking up the
tech
tech companies very clearly um now she
didn't win
and i suspect that won't happen but i
also suspect that google might be smart
enough to see
they should do something more than just
put privacy perfume on chrome they
should maybe get rid of doubleclick or
something divest something
i don't know it might happen so so brave
might inspire google to completely
change the way they're doing things
they're already doing something you may
have read about called the privacy
sandbox
or um flock which they have this bird
metaphor going
um turtledove um fledge
but these these these systems have been
very googly
kind of over engineered and yet
depending on differential privacy which
has weakness over time if you know how
that works it's kind of injecting
noise to hide you in a crowd but over
time an adversary can pull you out of
the crowd
that this doesn't look like it's going
to become a standard like apple
brave mozilla we're not going to just
say oh google you saved us
you've invented the privacy sandbox so
we'll all just adopt it
not going to be that easy it's going to
be more like pieces of what we do in
brave the synonymous ad matching or the
blind signature cryptography we used to
confirm the ad impressions that's david
chum's
invention that could get standardized in
fact some of that is being standardized
even google's in favor of so-called
trust tokens which are chow mein
blind signature certs but they're not
using them for ad confirmations because
they don't want to blow up their own
business
and they need to let some of the
publishers they serve
have other ad tech scripts on the page
and so they're kind of caught and this
is something i realized doing brave i
thought
what's you know google's innovator's
dilemma apart from just you know
being mature and having trouble
innovating it's that they have come to
depend on
this ad tech system that has all these
these
vendors that are publishers rely on
because publishers aren't technical
enough
and i feel for the publishers but i
realize the users have to come first and
if you give the users
a better browser that's faster then
you'll get enough users to to give back
or support publishers
the speed and the battery savings and
data plan savings are significant
there's so much bad javascript involved
in ad tech
if you block it you sort of chop off the
what's called the programmatic waterfall
which chains a bunch of requests yeah
that's one of the incredible things
about brave
i guess you're saying you should
attribute it to the fact that the the
messy javascript
no offense not much
uh is uh i mean brave just feels
faster even then i mean chrome was fast
and one of the things that it was like
impressive it showed that browsers could
be really fast and brave is even faster
than that which is blocked so much and
it saves
the network it's it which means data
plan it saves battery because the radio
consumes your battery when it's running
more to do those requests
and it's just stunning how many there
are like some of my google friends were
like oh that's just that bad site
they'll fix it
and you actually do a survey of web
pages they're like mostly like that
i know google google engineers could
make everything super efficient but they
can't
especially in anti-trust court do it
they cannot take over
all the publishers and do that they're
trying with accelerated mobile
profile amp they're trying to pull
publishers they're like oh you poor
publishers don't know how to make your
pages fast
put them on our amp system we'll give
you extra placement in the search
carousel
that's an antitrust problem for one but
it's also publishers we talk to hate it
because it degrades their brand
now they look like a gig writer wrote a
piece that's got
google's framing and amp url on top of
it and they're trying to fix that too
but
it just looks like a google's borgifying
all these publishers and they don't want
to be plugged into the board cube they
want to
build up their own brand and have loyal
readers so you know i'm in favor of
giving the users power to help all the
publishers and the little platoons and
the creators
you